What I'm going to talk about today is to continue our discussion about what is
biomedical engineering and go a little bit further and we'll spend about half
the class doing that.
And then I want to spend the last half of the class talking about some
biological structures that are very important and that you might not be familiar
with,
but I'll talk about biological membranes and lipids and how,
uh,
how they're assembled.
But first,
so first I want to start with the assignment I gave you last time when I asked
you all to think about these two questions and write some things down.
And let's,
let's start with the first with ey on this list here.
What,
what products of biomedical engineering have you encountered?
And we've talked about a few of these last time,
but,
uh,
I'm sure there's others.
So what,
what things did you come up with as you were thinking?
Anybody?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
so in the category of already available
drug delivery patches
and these are now available for,
for a variety of,
of drugs scope Allah means.
So for motion sickness was one of the first that was available.
Um,
and uh,
uh,
Nitroglycerin for treating heart disease is already available and these are
really like bandaids,
but they're bandaids that are loaded with drugs and they're designed in such a
way that if you apply this,
uh,
this,
this bandaid with adhesive to your skin drug will enter your bloodstream from
the bandaid through the skin.
And that's been,
uh,
that's I think a good example.
Others?
Yeah.
Dissolvable stitches or sutures.
Now what,
what needs to be engineered in those?
So they,
they have to be engineered to be a nerd so that they can be safely inside a
system and there's not,
not every material you could pick would have that property.
And it's a,
it's a suture or stitch has to hold the wound closed.
So it has to have certain mechanical strength and imagine the problem of making
something that's dissolvable so it disappears,
but also is strong enough to hold a wound close reliably for a length of time.
Others,
yeah,
arthroscopic surgery.
And so what do you,
what are you thinking about there?
Yeah.
So you can think about the instruments that they use and arthroscopic surgery.
Arthro means joint scopic means looking.
So it's looking into a joint and these are instruments that have very fine sort
of,
uh,
needles on the end,
but also cameras in them and you can put them inside a joint and then look
around and see what's happening inside.
And not just a camera,
but there are also tools on the end of these things.
So you can,
you can cut and uh,
you can do manipulations,
uh,
through this instrument.
So that's,
that's a great example also.
Yeah.
Hearing aids,
that's a good one.
Others?
Yeah,
cochlear implants.
So that's um,
um,
the same kind of a function as a hearing aid to improve,
uh,
to improve hearing but,
but using a different mechanism,
not just an amplification system that you put in your year,
but actually an implant that replaces the function of an organ inside your ear.
That's a good example.
Others,
it must be a couple of others.
Yeah.
Contact Lenses.
Yup.
Lasik surgery
now,
why,
why that one?
What makes you think of that as a example?
Instruments,
it involves lasers and learning how to make lasers that can,
um,
do the right amount of damage to tissue,
right.
Because that's what the laser is doing and the surgery is cutting like a knife
would do.
Uh,
but doing the right amount of damage and controlling it with the,
with light is an advanced there.
Others?
Yeah.
Tissue culturing.
Now what
to be engineered in a tissue culturing.
I beg your pardon.
So what,
what kinds of engineering do you think goes on behind that?
The technology that they use and,
and really there's quite a lot of technology here starting from the plates that
you grow them in,
turn out to be engineered so they have the right properties.
And we're going to talk about this more when we talk about,
uh,
about cell culturing,
later and,
and we'll talk about lots of potential applications of that as well.
Yup.
Dialysis.
And this is a method
to,
uh,
replace or augment the function of your kidneys to remove,
waste products really from the blood,
which is something the kidney does continuously.
Yeah.
Cosmetic surgery.
And you gave two examples.
One was botox
and the other was,
uh,
was a liposuction.
So two different kinds of strategies,
right?
One is a surgical strategy,
actually removing tissue.
When we talked a little bit about the engineering of surgical instruments and
things like and all,
so there's a lot of biomedical engineering that goes into everything that
happens in the operating room.
And Botox is an injection of a molecule,
right?
Or a complex molecule,
but a molecule.
Um,
so how,
in what ways would that be biomedical engineering.
So,
right.
And I think all those are good.
So there's,
there's lots of different ways.
One is in terms of how you deliver the molecule so it goes where you want it to
go and not where else she wanted to go.
And that's an engineering problem that we're going to talk a lot about how to
deliver drugs so that you get the action that you want at the site that you want
and not the toxicity,
right?
If you delivered botox all over your body,
that wouldn't be a good thing.
Might not even be a good thing if you deliver it in one place in your body.
But it's definitely not good if you deliver it everywhere.
And so controlling the dose is really important and that's going to turn out to
be very important in cancer therapy,
right?
Because these are very potent drugs that will have bad effects and other sites
and you want to localize them where they want.
So we're going to talk about that,
but I think this is a good list.
So let's go and,
and think about,
uh,
what might be a little bit more challenging.
Uh,
so in the future,
what things do you think,
uh,
biomedical engineering is going to produce in the future?
Yeah,
an AIDS vaccine.
Uh,
robotic surgery.
Yeah.
Robotic surgery.
Yup.
Artificial artificial hearts that can be used long term.
And that,
and that is a,
there's probably several elements to that.
One is,
one is longterm,
making them compatible with the body so that you could tolerate it for long
term.
And the other thing means if it's going to be long term than probably it has to
be implantable.
And that means all of the heart has to be implantable.
Right?
And this is where we don't have something that satisfies both of those
categories right now.
So imagine how much power it takes to drive an artificial heart.
So you've got to have a battery or some way of generating power continuously.
Um,
yeah.
Uh,
to operate that and that makes it difficult to think about implantable.
And so that's a really good example of biomedical engineering.
Yup.
Yeah.
Food supplies,
food,
food from cloned animals.
And we're gonna talk about cloning next week,
but why would,
why would cloning be an advantage in,
in producing food?
Okay.
Control the quality because cloned animals are all genetically identical.
Right.
And so you wouldn't have variability that in that way.
And so potentially you could have,
you know,
pick an individual that has really good quality meat and,
and uh,
and always reproduce that same
thing.
Yeah.
Genetic Scans for a disease
prediction.
And we talked about one way you might do that using gene chips last time.
We talked very little about that.
And so we'll talk more about that next week.
But certainly a technology is going to be available and there,
but there's going to be need to be ways developed to put this technology
together,
right?
If we looked at all 30,000 genes that were important in each individual,
how do you pick out which ones are important for a particular disease or what?
And often it's not going to be just one gene,
right?
It's going to be combinations of genes.
And how do you predict the fate of the individual based on all of the genes that
you know to be involved in progression of a certain disease?
Right?
So it's not just knowing what genes are figuring out ways to look at gene
expression,
it's figuring out how this expression of key genes affects the fate of the
individual.
Right?
And that's really a complex systems problem.
The kind of problems that engineers are very good at at,
at dealing with
others.
A couple more.
Yeah.
So I'm gonna,
I'm gonna call that chips implanted in the brain to control prosthetics,
but I'm going to make it a little bit more general and call it a brain machine
interface.
So some way of interfacing activity in your brain with,
with the outside world.
And uh,
we'll,
we'll talk about this as we go along,
but there's lots of reasons to think that we're,
uh,
that we're going to have this in the,
in the not too distant
future generations.
Yeah.
Spinal cord regeneration.
That's a good one.
Yup.
Sure.
Oregon or Oregon or that can be cultivated or anything like a single style.
Uh,
so Oregon's
grown from single cells.
Yeah.
I didn't,
I didn't hear the last part.
Be able to do like an X.
Right.
Oh,
so,
um,
so imaging,
okay.
Of moving parts,
like the joy,
like a joint or another moving part that might be interesting to look at.
Emotion is the heart,
right?
If you could,
if you could image how the heart is,
is moving,
you would know a lot about its function.
You can patch,
you learn a lot about its function by,
by looking at how it moves,
not just a static picture of it.
Right.
And there's lots of parts of our bodies that,
that move the lungs for example.
And um,
so yeah,
that's a good one.
Two more.
Yeah.
Artificial,
artificial pancreas.
Now how are you thinking that might work?
So,
so maybe,
and here are thinking about the,
the,
the pancreas has many functions,
but one of its important functions is to secrete insulin.
And so,
um,
and diabetics have lost that normal function.
So what if you could take just a pump that's able,
it's capable of continuously administering insulin at various rates and connect
it to a sensor that's able to continuously measure the sugar level in your
blood.
Right?
And insulin is important for regulating levels of sugar in your blood.
Well,
if you can continuously measure and then give the amount of insulin you need to
compensate for that amount of blood,
those things could work together to be a totally artificial pancreas.
Meaning tote made it totally out of synthetic parts.
Now another approach would be to take pieces of the pancreas that already have
all that capability within them.
And individual cells of the pancreas are capable of,
of a healthy pancreas,
are capable of both sensing glucose and secreting insulin.
So what did,
you can take cells from a healthy individual and put them into a diabetic
individual than maybe those new cells you put in would function as a totally
natural artificial pancreas.
Now,
why isn't that done?
Yeah,
why,
why doesn't that already work
do you think?
What are the engineering problems to overcome to get that to work?
Okay.
The same problems with organ transplantation is that the recipient has to be
matched to the donor.
And so that's a,
that that's a problem.
And uh,
that's,
that's a big problem.
And so can you protect these cells that you give to the recipient from attack by
the recipient's immune system?
That's one challenge.
And we'll talk about ways to think about engineering approaches to,
to solve that problem.
One more.
Yeah.
Control of angiogenesis.
And angiogenesis.
Angio means a blood and genesis means new.
And so angiogenesis is a development of new blood vessels.
And many people believe that tumors,
most tumors require blood vessels in order to grow.
If a tumor starts to grow and it doesn't develop a vascular supply,
it doesn't develop blood vessels in it,
then it can't get bigger than a certain size.
And there's lots of evidence for many cancers showing that this is true.
So if you could stop a tumor from being able to develop blood vessels,
you might be able to stop its growth and its stage where it's not harmful.
In fact,
I don't know if in the news that the pioneer in this is a man named Judah
Folkman who was a surgeon who first first speculated that this was important and
sadly he died on,
uh,
on,
Monday,
uh,
but had a dramatic impact on our understanding of how cancers develop in people
and new approaches.
And so there already are some approaches like this that are,
that are working.
Uh,
but there's more that needs to be done.
So,
um,
of these things that are up here,
are any that seemed controversial to you or that you would have said wasn't on
my list and I wouldn't say that that's biomedical engineering.
Okay.
Controversial in what sense?
Controlling your body where it was that
so,
so controversial has sense that maybe it's not a good thing to do or there might
be some limits on what we want to do there in terms of integrating machines with
people's brains.
And I think that's probably probably right.
And it might be some of the others here where there might be some,
uh,
some concerns or are there others that have kind of concerns like that?
Yeah.
And so some issues about how these technologies might be applied,
right?
If you had genetic scans that were available for disease prediction,
do you want to know everything that's going to happen to you in terms of
susceptibility to disease?
Well,
probably you want to know some of it,
but you might not want to know all of it,
right?
You might not want to know all of it.
And that's a really complicated a question for an individual to figure out and a
complicated question for society to figure out what you want to make available,
uh,
in that regard.
Yeah.
And if you can,
if you can start to predict,
well,
you're going to,
you're going to have heart disease that starts to develop when you're 45 and
you're looking to buy insurance when you're 30 or you're looking for a job when
you're 30,
and that information is available to your insurance company or your employer
that could have dramatic effects right on,
on,
uh,
the,
the choices that you get to make.
And so that,
that's,
that's really does,
these are really difficult questions to answer and we'll,
we'll,
we'll talk about,
we'll raise these issues as they come up.
We'll try to raise them with all the technologies.
We won't try to answer them.
Uh,
there are probably better people at Yale to answer those kinds of questions than
I am.
We'll talk about the technology and the,
and the questions that it brings up,
but I hope some of you get interested in these would be good topics to think
about for term papers as well.
For those of you that have that kind of inclination.
Um,
but any that seemed like controversial or or,
or like I don't think that's biomedical engineering or that's not what I want to
learn about in this course.
And you put it that way.
I hope we don't spend a week talking about that one.
Cause that's not what I thought.
Biomedical engineering was.
Any of these were they all seem on the mark.
Okay.
Yeah.
Food from cloned animals.
You didn't expect that to be biomedical engineering.
Yeah.
So what,
why we,
it came
that and making it
so I think I see where you wouldn't,
you wouldn't see it.
I see how you could put in that category and how you would be surprised to put
in that category.
It should be in the category because it's,
it's engineering to be able to do this.
Right.
And it's a biological system that you've engineered from taking cells from one
organism and cloning them and developing a whole nother organism.
And it's also engineering that helps humans,
right.
Because nutrition is one going to be one of the big problems of your generation,
How them have enough nutritious food for the population as it grows.
And even to understand what individuals should eat.
What should I be eating?
That's a really complicated question that we've gotten very confused about,
uh,
in large part because our government has confused us about it,
but,
uh,
but it's a confusing question to know.
Uh,
and um,
and so I think engineers have a role to play in that.
Um,
but it's not sort of classical biomedical engineering and the way that
developing an artificial heart is where you can see that.
Right?
But I think it's a good example of a place where biomedical engineers or the
future are going to contribute.
So I want to try to put this together into a form that I've come to understand
what biomedical engineering is,
um,
and,
uh,
presented to you.
Um,
and not only am I not an ethicist and I'm not good at those kinds of problems.
I'm not much of an artist either.
Um,
so this is a person you can,
you can recognize it as a person.
Uh,
but let's say it was a person a long,
long time ago and there was a point when one person,
uh,
decided to take instruments that were around them and use them to improve their
life.
You know,
somebody thought about a wheel or some group of people discovered how to use a
wheel,
some a knife and,
and some levers.
And these were very useful things and improving the quality of their life.
And that was probably that,
that's who you would call the first engineer,
right?
And then some,
it couldn't have been too long after those instruments became available,
but somebody will call them the first biomedical engineer decided to use those
instruments to look at either themselves or probably more likely their neighbor,
right?
Take a knife and open up the skin and let's see what's inside,
how do these fascinating things around me work.
And so people started turning these machines they developed on themselves to try
to understand how they worked.
Right?
And this is one aspect of biomedical engineering,
developing tools that allow you to understand how humans function and what's
wrong when they have disease.
And so some of the things we've talked about have that have that category.
Um,
um,
arthroscopic surgery in one sense is a,
is a fancy example of that,
a way of looking inside a joint to see what's happening inside a while the
person is alive and without hurting them.
Um,
and,
uh,
imaging of moving parts that same way is sort of an advance in that,
oops,
I hit the wrong one.
Um,
and as these tools became applied more and more widely,
we learned more about how human physiology worked.
And as we learned about how humans operate,
uh,
we could start to design machines that would help humans when they weren't
functioning properly.
And I think the simplest example was that once we learned that there were bones
or hard elements inside the leg and that those bones were important in keeping a
leg straight so that you could stand up than somebody could invent an artificial
bone,
a splint that would be wrapped around that would be secured to the outside of
the leg to give you a mechanical support even after you fell out of a tree and
you broke your leg.
Right.
And so this is another kind of engineering and engineering,
not to look more closely at how humans work,
but an engineering to improve their function,
uh,
when it's failing.
And as time goes on,
we've developed ever more complex machines to study people.
And we've talked about some of these already EKG machines.
So an example of an electrical device that can be used to monitor a very
elaborate function deep inside your body,
the beating of your heart and the rhythm of your heart.
And we talked about modern imaging methods and this is an example of an Fmo Ri,
a functional Mri,
uh,
um,
a map of the brain that not only shows you the anatomy of the brain,
but shows you something about the chemistry of what's going on inside.
And you can put somebody in an MRI machine now and have them read a book and
look at what parts of their brain become activated when they're reading and what
parts stop activating when they stop reading.
So you can learn where in their brain is reading done.
You can ask them to read French and to read Spanish.
And you can find different locations in the brain that are involved in
processing of those different languages.
And these are,
uh,
really incredible tools for understanding deep inside the body what's happening.
And we can even understand it on a molecular or cellular level now.
So this is a picture of a patch clamp.
It's a device that engineer's built to facet on to individual cells,
uh,
in order to look at how molecules in the membrane of the cell are working.
And I'll,
I'll talk a little bit about that as we go along.
So we can understand down to a very fine level now because of machines that
we've built and as our understanding has improved and we've been able to build
more complicated approaches to,
uh,
to replacing function.
We talked about the artificial hip,
which is a modern precursor of the splint I talked about before.
Much more sophisticated in terms of the,
that are required and the design thinking that goes behind it.
So now somebody can get an artificial hip and they can live for many decades
with it.
And have almost full function of that hip over that period of time.
Uh,
this is an example of a,
of a rudimentary brain machine interface.
It's a device called a,
a deep brain stimulator developed by a company called Medtronic and it looks
like a pacemaker that's implanted inside your body.
Here is a pacemaker and this pacemaker does the same thing that a heart
pacemaker does.
It generates periodic electrical signals,
but instead of those signals going to your heart,
they go into the brain that go through these wires and into these electrodes
that are deep in your brain and they stimulate tissue inside the brain.
And we've found that stimulation,
electrical stimulation deep in the brain can help patients that have Parkinson's
disease and can reduce the tremors and loss of muscle control that many patients
with Parkinson's disease use.
Now these are electrodes that are only sending out signals right there.
They're producing electrical signals in the brain.
They're not recording from the brain,
but it's not that big of a difference.
Right.
And,
uh,
it won't be long before we're using these same kinds of devices to both record,
to test what's going on and to act in the right way in response.
And this is the beginning of a real interface between machines and brains and
dialysis.
This is an example of a,
of a membrane dialysis unit.
Dialysis has done millions of times per day in this country and around the world
and keeps people alive when their kidneys have failed and they wouldn't survive
for even a week without dialysis.
And you can keep people alive for many decades with periodic dialysis to remove
waste products from the blood.
So we'll talk about,
um,
these,
uh,
these examples.
What I want to leave you with is,
is my picture not a very elaborate picture of what biomedical engineering is to
me and two parts of it.
One,
developing ways to understand how humans work better,
how human physiology operates,
and second,
developing new approaches for replacing function in people when they're sick.
I want to talk about,
uh,
move on and talk a little bit about some general concepts from physiology that
are really important.
And here is a table that gives characteristics of an average person and this
would be an average adult male,
uh,
30 years old,
the average height and weight and a surface area and temperature and lots of
characteristics of,
of an average,
uh,
person.
And let's think about some of these like,
wait,
um,
we think a lot about weight in this country,
uh,
but wait is a remarkably carefully controlled parameter of a person that is,
you have to work pretty hard to gain weight or to lose weight,
right?
We take in a lot of food and water every day,
every year and yet most of us,
our weight stays remarkably stable over that period of time for adults,
right?
Despite how much we eat and how much we drink.
And your body is able to regulate your weight fairly well without you really
thinking about it.
And anybody,
you're all too young to have tried to lose weight yet.
But when you get to be older and you start to think about as your metabolism
changes,
trying to control your weight,
you realize how hard it is to do right?
And you know this because people spend a lot of energy thinking about it.
Wait,
does remarkably well controlled.
If you let your body do its business
also temperature,
you can measure your temperature and you'd find variations throughout the day or
maybe some throughout the year,
but within a remarkably narrow range,
your temperature is controlled.
When you go from here to going outside to going to a much hotter room,
your temperature stays the same and your body is able to control this on your
own.
You don't have to think about it,
and in fact,
temperature is such a carefully controlled parameter that when it changes just a
little bit by a couple of degrees,
we know that something's wrong,
right?
You measure your temperature is a little up,
you've got a fever,
something's wrong.
I better find out what that is.
It's because temperature is a very highly controlled variable and you could go
through a lot of these parameters and think about it in the same way that these
things are really very highly controlled.
Well,
that process of control to maintain a constant environment inside our body,
whether it's an environment of constant mass or constant composition or constant
temperature is called homeostasis.
Your body has elaborate mechanisms for maintaining this state of homeostasis.
That is things staying the same,
the body stays the same homeostasis.
And this,
in spite of the fact that we take a variety of chemicals into our bodies in
different ways,
and we have to do that to stay alive,
uh,
but are we have mechanisms to control this very well.
So homeostasis is enabled by sometimes complex,
sometimes very simple control mechanisms.
And these are mechanisms that can be described not too differently from
mechanisms that you're familiar with,
for maintaining homeostasis.
For example,
the thermostat in your,
in your dorm room,
maybe you don't control thermostats in your dorm room.
Some of you do and some of you don't.
Probably a,
and maybe it doesn't work very well,
so it might not be a good example.
But imagine a perfect thermostat that you set for a temperature and then the
temperature stays the same inside the room,
no matter what the temperature is outside.
Well,
how does that work?
It works by a control mechanism called negative feedback,
and that the thermostat is measuring the temperature.
Okay.
The thermostat is measuring the temperature and then sending a signal to a
heater somewhere.
If the temperature drops below a certain level,
it sends a signal turn on the heat.
Okay.
And that signal stays on until it gets a negative signal to turn off.
When does that negative signal happen?
When the temperature gets above the level you want it to be,
right.
And so that's a negative feedback control system.
The heater is on,
it's producing heat until a negative signal is registered.
Oh,
we've gone to high and then it turns off.
And our bodies have mechanisms like that that mainly use the principle of
negative feedback in order to control the parameters that are important for life
within a certain range.
So why is temperature,
for example,
such an important thing to control?
Why?
Why are all of us in this room within plus or minus a few tenths of a degrees at
37 degrees centigrade or 98.6 degrees Fahrenheit?
Why is that such an important thing?
Yeah,
because that's the temperature at which many of the molecules in our bodies
operate at their most efficient.
And enzymes is the best example of that.
Enzymes work best enzymes are proteins that catalyze chemical reactions in our
bodies,
operate by elaborate networks of chemical reactions.
And our enzymes are optimized to work at 37 degrees.
When we're off from that temperature,
then they don't work properly.
Right?
And there are other examples as well,
but that's uh,
that's why it's important.
Um,
so we're going to think about,
uh,
in the next few weeks,
we're going to think about,
um,
the human organism at different levels of magnification.
And I've shown those levels here.
Uh,
the whole human organism is made up of a collection of organs and organ systems.
you know,
this,
the cardiovascular system,
which is the heart and the blood vessels which are responsible for and the
blood.
And so this is responsible for moving blood around the body and the blood brings
oxygen and nutrients to every part of the body at,
you know,
that.
And,
uh,
organs,
organ systems like the cardiovascular system are made up of tissues and tissues
are collections of cells that are working in synchrony for some function.
So the heart,
for example,
has a muscular tissue.
It has a very well developed muscular tissue and its function is to contract and
relax,
contract and relax.
And as it does that,
it changes the volume of the heart and gives the,
creates the pressure that moves blood around your body,
right?
So it has,
it has that muscular system.
It also has a blood vessel system in it.
The muscles of the heart have to get blood themselves.
So they have blood vessels.
Inside your stomach is a very complex organ that has a muscle layer.
It has an epithelial layer,
which is the interface with food that comes in.
Um,
and it also has a nervous system,
right?
So does the heart,
So Oregon's are made up of combinations of tissues where all the tissues are
collections of cells that are doing some function,
nervous tissue,
muscular tissue,
epithelium,
tissue are,
those are examples of tissues that form that form a organs.
And so here I just show tissues at two levels of magnification.
And when we think about tissues,
we're going to be interested in a couple of different characteristics.
One at the first level,
what are the cells that make up that tissue?
Because the cells are the fundamental component of our bodies,
right?
And very interesting because all of ourselves and our bodies share many
characteristics,
right?
And some of those characteristics are shown on this picture.
They have a nucleus,
they have a cell membrane,
they have organelles throughout them.
They have the same DNA.
All of your cells have the same DNA.
So the same genetic information and yet cells in your brain and cells in your
heart and cells in your kidney do very different things,
right?
So how can cells which have the same sort of master information,
DNA in your brain and your heart and your kidney be so different?
That's a question and it's one that we'll talk about in in weeks to come.
And how do those differences between cells contribute to the properties of the
tissues which contribute to the properties of the organs,
which contribute to the properties of a person.
And this maintenance of homeostasis and the main function of all yourselves and
all your tissues and all your organs is to maintain this homeostasis which
allows you to live in a changing environment.
All right.
And we're,
so we're going to spend the first few weeks of the course talking about first
DNA and genes.
We'll talk about how they work and I will go over that quickly cause I know most
of you know something about how Dna,
what DNA is and how it works.
But then we'll talk about engineering of DNA and why this has been such a,
not only a rapidly growing and advancing area,
but one that's so important for uh,
for biomedical engineering.
We'll talk about cells and how they work,
how cells in different parts of the body are different,
why and how they contribute to tissues.
And it in a very sort of simple level so that you can understand this as we
start thinking about using cells for engineering purposes.
So I want to just highlight what's in chapter two because I told you we're not
going to cover the details in chapter two in the course.
Uh,
but,
but this,
I give it to you as a resource so that you can,
you might have other books which described this which you like and you've read
already.
And so,
but I'm going to assume that you understand this information to some,
uh,
to some extent.
And again,
if you don't and you feel like you'd like a review session on this,
please send me an email and I'll set one up.
Uh,
next week I do want to talk about one in one important,
a subject which you might not have thought too much about.
And that's lip ids because lipids are so important to the structure of the body
because they make up the membranes that formed the cells that are the
fundamental units and lipids are really complex molecules on their own,
right.
But because of their particular kind of complexity,
they allow certain biological structures to form.
So most of the lipids which make up cell membranes in your body are of this
category of Phospho Lipids.
They're derived from a precursor called triacylglyceride,
which is a glycerol molecule with three fatty acid chains dangling off of it.
And fatty acid chains are fat molecules.
They behave if you have a lot of them in solution like oil,
and that's what triglycerides are like.
They're just like oil.
So if you had,
if you had a jar full of triglycerides,
it would,
it would behave like an oil mo.
Many would be liquid at room temperature.
What happens if you add them to water?
You get salad dressing,
right?
You get glob.
If you mix it,
you get glob of oil or globules of triglycerides that are floating around in the
fluid.
If you mix it,
if you let it sit,
they settle out into two phases again,
right?
That's how triglycerides behave.
Now if you've gone to the,
to the,
uh,
doctor,
the often they'll measure your triglyceride level as a,
as a measure of how healthy your liver is.
And how healthy your diet is,
having too much triglyceride or fat in your,
uh,
in your blood.
The wrong kinds of fat in particular is not considered a good thing,
but you need some of it because some of it gets converted into molecules called
Phospho.
Lipids and phospholipids are different.
They have to fatty acid chains and so these are the oily like parts of the
molecule,
the molecules that behave like oil and then link to the glycerol instead of a
third fatty acid chain is a water soluble molecule like assault and often it's a
salt called phosphocholine.
And so you get a phospholipid a that's made of uh,
of Coleen and two lipid chains.
Now this behaves very differently in water because part of it is water soluble.
This part is,
it's a molecule that would like to dissolve in water and part of it is like oil.
It doesn't want to dissolve in water.
So what happens when you put these molecules in water?
Well instead of forming droplets like fat,
they,
they arrange in a very particular way.
They form these structures that are called self assembled structures because
they occur naturally because of properties of the lipids.
But the lipids will form a bi layer where the water soluble part of the lipid
points out of this layer.
And uh,
and the oily part points in.
And the fascinating part about this layer is that it solves the problem for
phospho lipids about how do we exist in water when half of you wants to be an
oil and that the water soluble part of the top leaflet here of the top points up
into the water and the fatty acid chains point down the opposite leaflet does
the other thing that water soluble part points down in the fat points up.
So now you have a,
you have a thin region of fat
which is surrounded on both sides by water.
And this is a really interesting system because it also solves a problem for the
cell.
And the problem it solves for the sale is how do I make a barrier around myself
to define what's in me and what's outside of me,
when most of what's around me and what's in me is water.
So inside the cell,
mostly water outside the cell,
mostly water,
but I need to separate my water from the water outside.
Right?
And we'll see why they have to separate that in in a minute.
But they do that,
these,
these lipid biolayer solve that problem for them and their self assembled
structures from these,
from these molecules called phospho lipids.
Now that's not the only thing in cell membranes.
There are also proteins in cell membranes.
And these proteins are special proteins that can exist within,
uh,
within membranes like this.
And they exist because these proteins also have different segments with
different properties.
Some of the segments dissolve in water.
The great segments here and the lightly colored segments don't dissolve in
water.
They dissolve in fats.
And so they like to be in the membrane and they're stable.
They're,
and they won't come out right because there's structure allows them to exist in
these,
uh,
in these unique spaces.
So I'm going to stop there and we'll,
uh,
we'll,
we'll pick up on this topic not next week,
but the week after when we start talking about cell structure.
I wanted to introduce it to you so that if you don't,
haven't heard about this,
uh,
before,
you might want to read a little bit about this before we get to chapter five.
Next week we're going to talk about genes and genetic engineering.
That's chapter three.